sodexo et le département des yvelines
viennent d'officialiser la naissance de
ces midi actionnaires publics et
actionnaires privés réunis au sein d'une
structure qui au 1er janvier 2019
prendra en charge 114 collège
c'est un très gros marché pour nous et
c'est une excellente nouvelle pour
sodexo éducation puisque effectivement
le marché de marseille c'est à peu près
320 écoles avec 8 50 mille repas
produits chaque jour
et là nous sommes sur 48 mille repas
sont produits chaque jour pour le
département cette structure permettra de
favoriser l'utilisation de produits
locaux et bio 125 producteurs
franciliens seront ainsi sollicité à
mais aussi d'harmoniser l'organisation
de la demi pension avec une plus grande
équité dont le coût des repas pour les
familles actuellement il ya 74 tarifs
différents pour les 116 collège
désormais il y aura des tarifs iront de
1 euro à 4 euros en fonction des revenus
de la famille et le coût du repas est de
8 euros
c'est à dire que le département
continuera à subventionner de 50% à 90%
selon les revenus des familles le prix
du repas dans le cadre de cette
structure des contrats aidés seront
aussi développés et 70 postes de
responsable d'exploitation créé un
montant de ce contrat entre sodexo et
les yvelines 400 millions d'euros pour
sept ans